I can't imagine not creating things it's
the most fundamental and uncomplicated
joy that I can imagine I had two
grandparents who succumbed to cancer so
I'm really passionate about studying the
body the different processes that
facilitate its physiology
I love how kids can just smile they are
passionate about everything that they're
involved in and they want to learn they
want to grow and they want you to teach
them I love the life and joy that kids
bring I am most passionate about my
faith I just want to live in a way that
makes others wonder who or what I'm
living for
I hope to one day go back to Kenya and
contribute greatly to the field of
medical research and also provide
quality medical care to Kenyan patients
a dream of mine has always been to be a
scientific illustrator and Hillsdale has
helped me see how that's attainable by
giving me a strong classical training in
art and instilling in me how important
intellectual curiosity is whatever I do
whether it be pursuing baseball or a
career in the business world I just want
to be the man that God wants me to be my
greatest hope for my life is that I can
be successful as a teacher and what that
means to me is that I can teach kids
what I've learned here at Hillsdale
which is how to think and how to
question the world around me and become
the best versions of themselves
you